[Music]
one of the best things about the home
releases of marvel movies is that they
almost always come with a gag reel
here's some examples of marvel movie
bloopers we think might even be better
than the original scenes
in 2004 spider-man 2 peter parker isn't
finding young adulthood easy
he may have superpowers and genius level
intellect but the challenge of juggling
college multiple jobs a social life and
fighting crime as spider-man is proving
too much for him
in one of the many scenes meant to show
how parker is struggling he drops his
textbooks and as he kneels down to
retrieve them
multiple passing students whack him in
the head with their bags
the movie's gag reel shows us one take
when things went
even worse for parker although
thankfully mcguire has a good sense of
humor about it
shortly after parker is hit from behind
by one student's bag he's hit by another
from the front
a prompt shows us the second student is
none other than the director of the
first spider-man film trilogy
sam raimi although the extended
battering of peter would have definitely
made the finish scene funnier perhaps
raymie decided that choking his lead
actor with a backpack
was going a little too far on the
avengers gag reel mark ruffalo proves
himself to either have a
wealth of underutilized slapstick comedy
potential or to simply be the clumsiest
actor on just about any superhero movie
set you could find
in the middle of filming one of his lab
scenes with robert downey jr ruffalo
calls for the crew to wait
while he resets a prop which proves
easier said than done
careful electron set sorry
i got it it's okay it's coming
while this clumsiness actually would
have worked well for bruce banner's
character
it may have been a little too silly for
the high stakes world of the avengers
dude you're on your own
in what the avengers blu-ray calls
marvel's first ever gag reel
it's clear that director joss whedon's
trademark sense of humor
infected the entire cast
but whedon's not the only one who gets
to make you laugh as shield agent maria
hill kobe smulders doesn't get to flex
her comedy muscles in the mcu as often
as she did on how i met your mother
however she makes up for it with what's
arguably the funniest moment in the
avengers bloopers
pretending to react to the news of phil
coulson's death smulders has what we'll
call
a dramatic reaction
oh god you are the greatest man i ever
knew
we can't in good conscience pretend
maria hill's over-the-top meltdown would
have fit into the actual movie
but there's no denying it would have
been hilarious
the first time captain america iron man
and thor meet in the avengers things
don't go that well
the thunder god kidnaps loki from the
quinjet prompting iron man to fly after
him
intending to follow him cap grabs a
parachute and jumps out of the plane
but in the gag reel things went a little
differently on the reel chris evans
still grabs the parachute but has
absolutely no idea how to get the thing
on he struggles with it for so long that
it gets to the point where you start to
genuinely feel bad for the guy
i guess it literally go up as smoothly
as i was hoping
while it would have taken away from the
intensity of the scene showing this
in the finished film might actually have
made sense for the character
after all the last time steve rogers
used a parachute was decades earlier and
the design could have significantly
changed since world war ii
seeing steve struggle with his modern
parachute could have been yet another
amusing reminder that although you can
take the captain out of the 1940s you
can't take the 1940s out of the captain
in one of the funnier moments of 2014's
guardians of the galaxy michael rooker's
yondu
chooses a unique intimidation tactic
while the broker tries to explain why he
can't give yondu the information he
wants yondu keeps interrupting him with
gibberish
while this is already humorous in the
movie in the gag reel it ventures into
the realm of the absurd
as rooker just keeps going
behind him you can even see co-star sean
gunn trying hard not to laugh in a few
takes
sure we think the finished scene is
funny enough but adding in rooker's
extended gibberish monologue would have
taken it to the next level
sylvester stallone and kurt russell have
a few things in common
they both hit their fame sweet spots in
the 1980s
they both appear in 2017's guardians of
the galaxy vol 2
and both get frustrated on the sequel's
gag reel trying to spit out guardians
specific names
the gag reel shows that while playing
the ravager leaders to car stallone had
a lot of trouble nailing down the word
ravager
ravager
avenger what am i saying ravanger
no brav verger yes oh forget it i'll see
you in looping
meanwhile kurt russell has trouble
saying his son's code name
as he camps with the guardians russell
says well
even where i reside out past the edge of
what's known we've heard tell about the
man they call star wars
of course we all know the name he really
means to say is
star-lord who
star-lord man legendary outlaw russell
immediately realizes his mistake and
eventually manages to get his son's name
right
however leaving in the actor's mistakes
could have added a bit to the respective
scenes
showing stakar pronouncing ravagers
differently than yondu could have
highlighted the division between the two
of them
and the fact that ego keeps getting his
kid's name mixed up with that of a
popular earth movie franchise could
underscore
what a horrible father he is of course i
have issues
that's my freaking father the scene set
in the dystopian future of 2014's x-men
days of future past have a pretty bleak
tone so it almost feels wrong that the
movie even has a gag reel
but it's good that it does since the
outtakes are pretty hilarious
among other funny bits the gag reel
includes a ridiculous alternate version
of a deleted scene
before time traveling to the past to
prevent the dystopian future in which
the sentinels have hunted mutants to
near extinction wolverine turns to storm
after confirming that he'll be the only
one to remember this version of the
future he gives his teammate a long kiss
although the scene is likely supposed to
end there halle berry follows it up with
an unexpected reaction in the gag reel
although barry's response to the kiss
would have broken the bleak mood the
kiss itself
may have been a nice addition to the
finished film on the other hand sharing
a kiss with storm earlier in the film
might have made seeing her right before
wolverine's emotional reunion with the
previously deceased
jean grey at the end of the film
slightly more awkward
as far as mcu movies go 2016's captain
america civil war is pretty intense
the final throwdown between the warring
heroes gets ugly but thankfully one of
the architects of marvel comics shows up
toward the end to not only deliver an
important package to tony stark but to
make sure we get in a few laughs
in one of his many beloved marvel cameos
the late stan lee shows up to the
avengers headquarters as a fedex driver
delivering the package that contains a
letter from steve rogers along with an
emergency contact phone
in the finished product lee accidentally
misreads the name of the recipient much
to roadie's delight
are you tony's stank
yes this is this is tony stank you're in
the right place
thank you for that however the film's
gag reel shows a take where
lee says something else and we're not
sure if he did it on purpose or if it
was a legitimate goof
are you robert stank while the original
scene was hilarious fusing the
mispronunciation of the character's last
name with the actor's real-life first
name
could have been a fun fourth wall
breaking moment it even would have made
an odd sort of sense considering that
marvel has officially canonized the
popular fan theory that lee
is playing a watcher in all of his
cameos
the blooper reel on the home release for
2016's deadpool makes it clear that
several of the actors frequently veered
off script
deadpool's gag reel includes a wealth of
completely improvised lines particularly
from ryan reynolds and his co-star tj
miller for example
when miller's weasel first sees wade
wilson's scarred face
the comedian unleashes a torrent of
improvised takedowns
expressing his disgust at his friend's
new appearance you look like somebody
turned your face inside out and then
just left it like that
but then you got in a house fire god you
look like a house fire was in another
house fire
meanwhile reynolds own improv includes a
long list of jabs towards gina carano's
angel dust
leave me all alone here with buster
rhymes you're gonna leave me all alone
here with henry winkler
you know leave me all alone here with
hey you guys
hilariously the reel shows that the line
that made it into the theatrical release
ticked carano
off so much she gave reynolds an actual
punch to the face as a reward
sorry gina
while it's true that putting all of
miller's and reynolds improvised
outtakes into the finished film
probably wouldn't have worked from a
pacing perspective we wouldn't have
minded giving each of them an
opportunity to riff just a little bit
longer in each of these scenes
one of the most delightful parts of
2018's deadpool 2
is wade wilson's corrective time romp
during the mid-credits scenes
deadpool uses cable's repaired time
travel device to save his girlfriend and
his
x-force teammate peter prevent the
making of the 2011 film green lantern
and cut short the action of 2009's x-men
origins wolverine
but while negasonic teenage warhead has
a surprisingly easy time fixing the
device deadpool has a tough time
grabbing a hold of it
on the gag reel we learned that it took
ryan reynolds at least four takes to
catch the device without dropping it
considering how ridiculous the deadpool
films tend to be we can't help but
wonder if the main character repeatedly
fumbling the time travel device might
have actually played well in the film
maybe wade could have even capped the
moment with his signature slogan
maximum effort there's one little
wonderful nugget about the making of the
star wars prequels that fans of the
franchise love even if they aren't
particularly fond of the films
themselves
according to ewan mcgregor the obi-wan
kenobi actor would regularly make the
lightsaber
sound effects with his mouth during
fight scenes to begin with it was quite
difficult not to make the sound
yeah and also when it goes away because
it makes that nice
noise when it goes down well according
to the gag reel for 2017's thor ragnarok
mcgregor
isn't alone in accidentally trying to do
the sound team's job for them
kate blanchett plays the death goddess
hella in ragnarok and the gag reel
includes a few takes of different scenes
in which blanchett makes childlike sound
effects to accompany
the unleashing of her character's powers
do i should make the noises in my mouth
today
the gag reel also reveals that
blanchett's fight scenes with co-star
chris hemsworth offered other challenges
the oscar-winning actress had a tough
time dragging her co-star across the
floor as well as finding it tough to not
hit hemsworth for real
sorry guys i've been training for months
but i don't think i can lift that sure
maybe hella wouldn't have been quite as
intimidating if she was making her own
sound effects and fumbling her fights
with her super powered siblings but in a
film
filled with plenty of other visual and
audible gags including blanchett's goofs
may not have felt entirely out of place
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite marvel films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you